sammarinese benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video come avrete intuito dal titolo
oggi faccio il mio primo hai mai visto
che tanti di voi mi hanno chiesto questa
tipologia di video nel mio ultimo post
in sagra
ho chiesto a tutti voi insomma di farmi
tutte le domande che volevate che
iniziassero con hai mai
cercherò di rispondere nella maniera più
sincera possibile proprio senza filtri
allora davanti a me ho tutto necessario
cioè questa boccia di vetro corti
bigliettini con le vostre domande e
questi due fantastici cartoncini che ha
realizzato edo perché io non sono capace
neanche di fare una riga dritta e
ovviamente ogni risposta io sono un
cartoncino se la risposta è sì è un
cartoncino
se la risposta è no ovviamente
iniziamo subito questa ip
hai mai copiato a scuola ma forse sì
all'università un po più difficile
perché se ti sgamano abbastanza un
problema però ha qualche esame
qualcosina l'ho copiata anche
all'università
la meta è normale cattivo trovate mia
persona che non abbia mai copiato è hai
mai inviato un messaggio alla persona
sbagliata
allora no no no ma una volta è successo
che ha scritto un messaggio non è mica
dal telefono di mia mamma quando ero più
piccola
riguardo il farsi o meno un tatuaggio
insieme la mia amica ha risposto al
telefono mi ama pensando che fosse mio
mia mamma ha scoperto che volevo fare un
tatuaggio
bene hai mai fatto pazzie in amore
purtroppo sì purtroppo perché tutte le
volte che li ho fatte mi sono pentita mi
sono sentita una cretina perché le
persone per cui ha fatto pazzie non
sarebbe rita vano assolutamente quindi
ragazze prima di fare pazzie pensateci
bene
la dignità prima di tutto
e con questo mi chiamo hai mai tradito
in amicizia
allora assolutamente e categoricamente
no io sono una delle amiche più sincere
fedeli
le ali al mondo e
al contrario però come come sempre
quando uno è troppo bravo se la prende
sempre in quel posto quindi io non ho
mai tradito un'amicizia ma a me me ne
hanno fatte di tutti i colori insomma
hai mai fatto la terza incomoda
assolutamente sì ragazzi ho passato anni
anni della mia gioventù a fare la
candela addirittura forse ve l'avevo già
raccontato un capodanno si avevo
raccontato un capodanno con sole coppie
ve lo ricorderete tutti perché l'ho
fatto l'ho raccontato nel capodanni top
flop e ma non solo c'è oltre al
capodanno ce ne sono stati tanti altri e
medi cene serate gu ero l'unica single
di tutta la compagnia capito
hai mai no sei mai caduta dai tacchi lo
so non me lo aspetteresti mai da me ma
sì sì perché ovviamente adesso sono
esperta sono una camminatrice ed
attacchi professionista ma quando ero
ragazzina come tutte le ragazzine alle
prime armi con i tacchi mese ho fatta di
quelle cadute anche in pubblico anche
davanti ai ragazzi mi piacevano che non
mi dimenticherò mai per tutta la vita
hai mai avuto una cotta per un tuo
parente che domandava comunque sì per un
mio cugino spagnolo e da piccola mi
sembrava brad pitt cioè che lo vedevo mi
sembrava un attore di hollywood quindi
aveva una mezza pop sì ma io avevo forse
4 o 5 anni plausibile dai ragazzi ci sta
hai mai subito delusioni da parte di
persone che ritenevi amiche come ho
detto prima essendo un'amica molto reale
molto buona me la sono sempre presa in
tutti i luoghi in tutti i laghi e in
tutti i due emisferi e
posso dire con sicurezza di avere avuto
più delusioni dalle amiche che dagli
uomini il che è tutto dire
hai mai pensato di farsi suora originale
anche quindi devo dire sì ma aspettando
aspettate sempre quando ero piccola
quando si è piccoli si hanno delle idee
molto bizzarre molto pittoresca mi
piaceva tanto andare a catechismo e
quindi ogni tanto forse meno forse una
volta sola ho detto a mia mamma mamma mi
piacerebbe fare da suora quella è stata
l'unica esperienza così un po mistica
dopodiché subito lo step successivo era
a mamma voglio fare la parrucchiera
quindi è subito andato in fumo il sogno
di fare da suora hai mai scoperto che
qualcuno ti parlava alle spalle l'asta
che il video ecco a voi ragazzi ma qua
proprio aprite una porta esatto e si è
già prima comunque di fare da youtube
rete ma adesso figuratevi cioè proprio
gente che mi fa il sorriso davanti e poi
dietro mi dici tutti i colori ma fa
parte del gioco ragazzi sorridere e
andare avanti
hai mai tagliato i capelli molto corti
[Risate]
si chiama aveva un caschetto e allora io
che dovevo tagliare i capelli guardo da
parrucchiere di coli voglio come la
mamma
peccato che la parrucchiera non mi ha
fatto un caschetto
non sto scherzando ragazzi automatico
per me mi ha praticamente fatti capelli
a spazzola
io facevo forse la quarta elementare e
cioè adesso ci rido su però fidatevi che
sono stata malissimo anche perché tutte
le mie amiche ovviamente nei comandi
classamenti capelli lunghi io gli volevo
un po più corti ma non cortissimi quando
vi chiedete perché non tagli ma i
capelli o abbastanza il trauma della
forbice del parrucchiere in è chiuso hai
mai bevuto fino ricordarti nulla
ebbene sì un po me ne vergogno però so
che tutti i ragazzini ci sono passati
non è sta non è una roba frequente cioè
sarà successo a 12 volte è una persona
super paranoica super ipocondriaca
quindi quando è successo non capire più
nulla non ricordarsi più niente una cosa
che il giorno dopo mi hai mandato non in
paranoia e di più e infatti poi non si è
più ripetuto assolutamente e quindi vi
consiglio anche a voi di non esagerare
mai con l'alcol perché è bello insomma
bere e divertirsi però fino a un certo
punto perché poi con si supera il limite
si sta davvero male non solo fisicamente
ma anche poi mentalmente
hai mai pensato di scappare di casa
no immagino che la domanda sia riferita
magari quando si adolescenti che siano
un po le crisi adolescenziali magari si
litiga coi genitori
e successo tutto anche a me però da lì a
dire scappò di casa non ci ho mai
pensato non avrei mai fatto anche perché
non hai mai finto di parole al telefono
per non salutare qualcuno è un classico
ragazzi è un classico t mamma sì sto
arrivando
sì l'ha scampata l'abbiamo fatto tutti
lo faremo sempre e va bene così hai mai
avuto una cotta per un prof
sinceramente no la tipologia professori
non è mai stata la mia tipologia
preferita anzi quindi no hai mai baciato
un ragazzo che non ti piaceva sì forse
una volta si giura tipo innamorato di me
non me non piaceva quindi mi sembrava
brutto quando si è avvicinato non
baciarlo però durato pochissimo è tuo
non l'ho più sentito
vabbè era tenero però non mi piaceva
ragazzi dai ci siamo non ti piace non è
che sono andata io lì così c'è la lui
che mi moriva dietro è una certa cioè
nel senso un bacino
gliel'ho dato però proprio tipo
vabbè mi hai mai corteggiato in amore ma
assolutamente no ragazzi io sono una
donna d'altri tempi cioè tutte le
ragazze che mi scrivono come faccio a
fargli capire che mi piace ragazzi non
c'è un modo per far capire un ragazzo
che che vi piace perché semplicemente
voi dovete fare la parte delle ragazze
da corteggiare punto anche se non di
morite dietro cioè io tutte le volte
magari di acetati suo ragazzo ancora di
più
mettevo la corazza e facevo la stronza
perché quella è la tecnica per fare
breccia nel cuore degli uomini
capito ragazzo è tutta psicologia
inversa hai mai nascosto un tatuaggio
dei genitori
ebbene sì penso il primo questo qua qua
dietro che ho fatto a 16 anni
ma poi dopo tipo 2 3 mesi forse ho
chiesto a mia mamma di spalmarmi la
crema e me l'ha visto io dico sì ho
fatto un tatuaggio lo volevo dire mai
marinato la scuola
mi sa di sì una volta sola una volta
sola e perché non è che successo perché
mi spiego brevemente io abbia miglior
amica decidiamo di tagliare quindi
andiamo farci un giro in centro è tutto
bellissimo aveva giorno dopo ci pieno
alla giustificazione ci facciamo ognuno
per conto suo la giustifica dei genitori
e la mia viene perfetta io faccio una
firma di via ma benissimo
la mia amica non era brava quanto me a
copiare le firme e ci hanno sgamato per
colpa della firma della mia amica
cazziatone proprio generale da parte dei
genitori dei protestanti dopo da quel
giorno prossima volta vai a scuola
piuttosto riprendi un 3 ma meno mi evito
il cazziatone per aver marinato hai mai
avuto una relazione distanza si per poco
tempo perché non sono tipo da relazione
distanza infatti è durato pochissimo
tanti di voi so che hanno graziani
distanza ben venga se siete capaci di
tenere a distanza tanto di cappello io
non sono capace per vari motivi e quindi
preferisco avere il mio fidanzato vicino
a mac
hai mai provato qualcosa per il ragazzo
di una tua amica
assolutamente no io sono proprio ferrea
su queste cose i ragazzi e gli ex
ragazzi delle amiche non si toccano
è una cosa che a me darebbe troppo
fastidio se succedesse a me quindi di
conseguenza non lo voglio fare agli
altri
e sinceramente non mi è mai successo
perché gravi amiche abbiamo gusti
completamente diversi hai mai baciato un
ranocchio sì allora lorient in amazzonia
c'era questo ranocchio verde che mi
guardava io ho subito pensato a stelo
bacio si personali un principio ho
baciato e in quello stesso istante ci
siamo catapultati in un castello in
normandia
simile a quello della bella e la bestia
lui era ancora più bello della bestia
trasformata da uomo e niente abbiamo
vissuto la nostra vita di felice con te
ovviamente no ragazzi ma che hai mai
fumato purtroppo sì ma ho smesso anche
lì quando ero ragazzina mi raccomando
ragazzi se fumate smettete perché fa
malissimo malissimo sia per le vostre
tasche perché si spende un sacco di
soldi e sia per la soprattutto per la
vostra salute
hai mai tradito
io allora aveva detto di essere sinceri
e quindi sarò sincera ho tradito sì una
sola volta
non mi sono sentita tanto in colpa per
il semplice motivo che secondo me non
era innamorata
quindi questa è la mia riflessione sono
convinta che se si è innamorato di una
persona non viene voglia di tradirla
sono infatti la storia è finita in
pochissimo tempo però non si fa nel
senso è teoricamente per essere proprio
belle persone bisognerebbe lasciare la
persona prima di frequentare qualcun
altro è successo una volta sola non l'ho
più fatto è però anch'io sono stata
tradita quindi voglio dire le cose
tornano vedete andiamo avanti
hai mai dormito durante una lezione
sì soprattutto all'università
soprattutto durante quelle elezioni
belle soporifere non lo so fammi un
esempio estetica del cinema sociologia
economia politica storia contemporanea
argomenti dobbiamo fatto quasi lo stesso
corso quindi
sappiamo bene quali sono le materie del
nostro corso soporifere hai mai fatto
una vacanza studio
sì quando avevo la prima a 14 anni fa
nata a malta e poi a 16 anni sono andata
in inghilterra in famiglia per due
settimane a bonn mons
sono state due esperienze diverse nel
senso a malta mi sono divertita molto di
più ora il mio primo viaggio da sola con
la mia migliore amica in inghilterra da
sola in famiglia avuto qualche
esperienza traumatica tipo che mi davano
il cibo scaduto
premendo anche il cibo non scaduto
faceva schifo
toast con le carote dentro per pranzo
tra l'altro lo stesso anno hanno trovato
hanno scoperto che c'era un killer
proprio in quel paese lì il famoso
assassino di beaumont che uccideva tutte
le ragazzine
mi è andata bene sono tornata a casa
viva
hai mai avessero apparecchio purtroppo
si è purtroppo nel senso meno male
perché adesso sono contenta dei miei
denti però ne ho visti tanti da piccola
ho messo anche quello di notte tremendo
che aveva tipo i ferri qua legato alla
testa una roba oscena io andrò a casa
delle mie amiche a dormire mi veniamo
tantissimo però ragazzi se anche voi
state mettendo l'apparecchio e vi
sentite magari a disagio tenete duro
perché alla fine quello che conta avere
un bel sorriso e da adulti vi servirà
tantissimo
ultima domanda è mai franzo nato
[Musica]
no credo di no sì forse una volta un mio
amico una compagna di banco mia scritta
di classe mi ha scritto il bigliettino
classico e finanziarti commessi o no
forse avevamo 13 anni e l'ho scritto il
sito no però sotto ps
voglio rimanere tua amica quindi sì
avevo pranzo nato però è che in vino
sicea pensionato quindi scusate ho avuto
un po di confusione
niente abbiamo finito la boccia e super
vuota spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto questo video sono stata super
sincera quindi la sincerità prima di
tutto vi mando un bacione e fatemi
sapere qui sotto quella domanda insomma
la risposta che è divertito di più e
quali sono le altre domande che vi
piacerebbe alle quali piacerebbe
rispondessi magari in un altro video e
niente vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video e pop ad ora
[Musica]